le petit café du matin c'est le plaisir
enfin retrouver à mes voisins avoir des
contacts avec les gens parce que si vous
restez chez vous ça donne rien c'est en
discutant c'est en discutant que on
apprend plein de choses un petit café à
mes voisins qui rouv d'ailleurs ça se
voit parce que tout le monde est revenu
l'arbre de la liberté c'est l'unique
commerce de ce petit village où ces 600
habitants peuvent retrouver les gestes
les plus simple il y a quelques mois
j'aurais dû me dire bon je vais je vais
où à saint-pia au village plus loin ou à
la ville plus loin et là en même pas 5
minutes j'ai du pain c'est génial ouvert
en décembre 2022 le restaurant fait
aussi épicerie la gérante a trouvé son
rythme de croisière et ses comptes
suivent entre 12 et 14000 € de chiffre
d'affaires par mois je suis bien niveau
comptabilité c'est
impeccable c'est ce que je m'étais fixé
après j'ai des petits évidemment des
petits réglages à faire mais on est bien
on est bien dans ce projet fou Anne
n'est pas seule la mairie a investi dans
le foncier et les habitants se sont
regroupés le Groupe SOS à l'origine de
l'initiative mil café a aidé la gérante
à se lancer mais l'accompagnement se
fait aussi sur le long terme il y a
toute la prise en charge de la
comptabilité et du juridique et de les
RH derrière la structure donc
l'établissement des contrats et et de la
comptabilité euh il y a et puis après il
y a tout l'accompagnement d'un référent
donc en l'occurrence moi qui va aider
Anne à piloter son établissement en
terme de gestion de développement de
l'activité de communication de maîtrise
des ratios et des marges les idées ne
manquent pas pour continuer à développer
le café pouvoir en faire un relais colis
ou encore vendre du tabac merci